Tyler - Give me another clap for safety because I think it might have been before I hit record
*Clap*
Jack - The power of friends!
*Laughter*
Mark - You're a garbage person
laughter from Mark and offscreen*
*Jack chuckles*
Jack - I'm having a fucking seizure
Jack - This electric boogie's fuckin' poppin'.
*Offscreen* Unce unce unce unce unce unce
Jack - Work it! Work it, Justin!
*thud*
Mark - Nice job there, what'd you break?
Ian - What was that?
Brizzy - Oh, did I smell honey? I'm GrizzlyVoices!
*roars*
*more roaring*
Mark - If you're ready to fight...
Mark - I'm all yours.
Mark - Why don't you come on then?
Mark - There's no one else here. We can be ourselves
Mark - Finally...
Mark  - This really sounds like we're leading into-
Mark - You're so brash...
Mark - When will you ever take an... elegant touch?
*mouth click*
*Ethan and Tyler laughing*
Jack - There it is again!
Mark - Damnit!
Ian - WOOOOOAH!
*slightly vigorous grunting*
*Mark laughing*
TJ - AAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHH!!!
Mark - There's nothing standing in the way of you taking what you want, so...
*loud laughter offscreen*
Mark - This is really gay!
Mark - It's really gay!
Kathryn -  Did your voice crack a little on that?
Mark - A little bit, yeah, as I realized how gay it was!
Mark - You seem to lack certain... charm...
Mark - Nope
Mark - I was gonna say someone better teach you some manners.
*everyone laughing*
Mark - Fuck!
Mark - *Slightly disappointed groan*
SharkYoHo - We're SharkYoHo. SharkYoHo, FIRE!
SharkYoHo - *singing* Yo, ho, yo, ho, a sharky life for me!
*Ian making weird sounds*
*Mark giggling in the background*
*Anti laughing*
*laughter*
*boop*
*everyone laughs*
Mark - I don't need to stand here for this, I could just- *laughs*
Jack - Yeah.
Jack - Oh, god...
*more vigorous grunting*
Mark - It seems that a young upstart like you needs to be taught some manners..
Mark - I've been... educated... in... certain ways [giggling]
Mark - to... discipline... bad boys. *giggling*
*offscreen laughter*
Mark - *clears throat*
Tom - Fuck!
*laughter*
- God, your superpower sucks!
Tom - Fuck you guys!
*laughter from everyone*
Jack - I could start smelling you
*more laughter*
Phil - I'm ABlazingPhil and when you come to Britain your tea will be cold and your crumpets will be burnt!
[Schmoyoho losing their sharkyoho character]
SharkYoHo - Avast!
Mark - Shut up
Mark - Shut up!
Jack - *whining* Guys shut uuuuup!
Mark - *whining* Shut uuuuup!
Kathryn - I was monologuing here! Dammit!
Jack - You just break character
Mark - *whining* Yeah, I was trahhz- doin' a thing!
*offscreen* "MOOOM!"
*offscreen* "Moooom..."
*Anti laughs*
*everyone else laughs*
*offscreen* - You just get everyone laughing!
Jack - I know!
*more laughter*
Mark - You don't know how funny it looks! *still laughing*
Jack - 'Cause I... I realized my shoulders were doing this!
Mark - Yeah, I know! *laughter continues*
Mark - That's so good!
Mark - I got this *clears throat*
Ian - *scared screaming*
*thump*
*evil bear growling*
Pam - My anxiety... it's just projection of my anxiety on others, I just-
No, I can't! *crying*
*Dan laughing*
*Offscreen* Nailed it. Nailed it.
Mark - Love it, done, nailed it, perf-
Mark - Perfect.
*Convulsive dying*
Tom - Beep beep, it's TomSKAR, and my yell can blow you up!
Tom - God, that feels good
Tom - Um, ah...  *laughter*
(big thud)
Phil - Oh my god!
Dan - Please tell me that was recording! *laughter*
Phil - I'm sorry! I told you I'd break everything!
Mark - *dramatically* My light!
Jack - Shark!
Mark - Bear!
*laughter*
Jack - Y-you need to give me time to get back up!
Jack - I'm still dodging sharks over here!
Mark - Sorry, okay!
Jack - Shark!
Mark - 1, 2, 3, BEAR!
Jack - ETHAN!!
*dab*
*offscreen laughter*
Mark - Wha?
[pretending to vomit]
Mark - BLEH
Mark - I dunno. Okay, alright. That's about as much as I've got.
Jack - *copying Mark's bleh*
Mark - Your turn! *laughs*
Anti - He's got four nipples!
*laughter*